big day today we have a very special
guest coming down you're gonna be
cooking for him and a chance to show
what we've been doing we've got Ken
Clark coming down he's the man that
oversees every big decision in the
justice system
yep so it's a big one I want to see some
energy in here I want you to do yeah
exactly and he's gonna like what we were
cheap let me put this way his he's the
[ __ ] side to him coming if you didn't
understand how important this is it's
placing a closed we have to make an
immediate impression
I know ken plant like seafood so I've
asked the boys to create traditional
British canapes to showcase what they've
learned he's taught me a better
discipline is told me I've got more
belief in myself now they've earned my
trust I can give him something without
lying I'll be doing myself literally two
hours later takes a long time to get
that trust
I never had a skill before even though
all have jobs I never have your skill
gives you other avenues yeah I mean got
any questions for Ken apparently just
welcome in there welcome to kitchen
voices you already sent him to sleep
he's away they might only be canapes but
today the Scotch eggs on the menu are
odd cuisine quails eggs peanuts about
I've never heard of this stuff in my
life yeah B can you [ __ ] believe it
I'm sold pepin your egg white goes
nothing in my mouth what my turn again
stick up your ass cuz you'll bring your
man I gonna meet it it's a quail egg I
just wanted everybody really probably
but yeah
the stakes are high and there's no room
for culinary cock-ups guys you're all
responsible for your own tray so when I
say go it literally is go test him that
go to earlier those ultra puddings
all right guys he's arriving littering
15 days from now all the horseradish on
the beef not knows but otherwise he'll
go soggy okay when he comes in here I
want to see some activity some
excitement yeah don't forget don't start
serving the food here I wanted to taste
it upstairs if you just understand how
important this is this place is gonna
close
oh I meant Thalia I'm the governor
welcome thank you it is okay you get
them like that with a runny yolk in
there bingo
yeah he's gonna piss himself the
government have said they want to see
more prisoners working full time I'm
convinced that the graft and commitment
from my brigade will prove what can be
achieved
well welcome what other than that I'm
having a nice time in Hastings prison a
a nice thing I find him in doing this
anything worse what we need is skills to
take on the outside with us to help us
along in life it's a special thing
that's going on here you know it's gonna
help me save my life here we are
the hello hey Clark nice to see welcome
yeah you are we're fine how are you good
to see you a very one thing that yeah um
Adonis hello there I'm innocent
Kent Clark test [ __ ] hello please Ben
these two gents were at the beginning of
the project right from day one we hand
porters for you for this to continue
I teach the new prisoners what I've
learned
yeah no you're not teaching new
prisoners yeah hopefully because it's a
business now with suppliant ask a pain
arrow so if I could cheer them to how to
make the toss
you know I guess you've got a brand new
have bad boys bakery I've changed it
taste so you got to do your time but
it's sensible that you do your time
preparing for a slightly more sensible
way of life when you get out yeah sure
yeah mr. Ramsay I'm told it's quite a
good cook I can do toast on a good day
but I've never this is just a small
insight to what they've been doing very
good well I'm complaining in cabinet
this morning we don't have biscuits
anymore so I'm looking for a Disney
lunch
I'll see surely for a little white
choice up in the office
so no wine that no red wine I'll see you
in five thank you okay guys close off
the treasure so far so good
but I'm hoping the waiter this ministers
wallet is through his stomach right guys
see you later yeah come on
I'll see you tomorrow
just remember by time you wake up
tomorrow morning you had the product
would be in caffeine arrow oh wow yeah
your eyes yeah I've witnessed my younger
brother triumph failed to go clean
countless times so spoken to my
restaurant manager at the Savoy Grill
and decided to give Paul a chance